Нам потрібна консультація лікаря - якнайшвидше.
Але профільний лікар має вільний час
лише у грудні - аж за 4 місяці!
Тож знаходимо лікарку-дерматолога,
яка на своїй сторінці пропонує консультацію онлайн.
Заповнюємо кілька даних про себе
і вже за лічені хвилини отримуємо консультацію.
Вітаю, пані Лащак, чим можу вам допомогти?
У мене останнім часом вкрай суха шкіра на руках.
Навіть трохи чешеться.
Але мене непокоїть насамперед сухість.
Пані Лащак, я гадаю, що внаслідок частого миття рук
послаблений захисний шар вашої шкіри.
Це викликає на руках так звану екзему.
Треба значно частіше змащувати їх кремом.
Онлайнвізит до лікаря обійшовся у 30 євро.
З огляду на те, що проблема вирішилася
швидко й просто, це було варте того.
Ми можемо провести огляд і в залежності від симптомів
та зовнішнього вигляду на базі нашого досвіду це оцінити.
І тоді вирішити, наскільки це терміновий випадок.
Звісно, особистого контакту це не замінить.
Діагностичний огляд, повторний контроль -
для цього все ще потрібні лікарні.
Ну, і прилади для точнішої діагностики.
Діагноз через відеодзвінок - це первинна консультація,
де достатньо лікарського ока. У Німеччині
тривалий час це було заборонено.
Лише з 2019 року лікарям дозволяється прийом пацієнтів
по відеочату. Це економить час та запобігає інфікуванню.
У часи коронавірусу лікарські відеоконсультації переживають бум.
Невже тепер це стане стандартом у медицині, як онлайншопінг?
Люди, наприклад, з хронічними хворобами зможуть надсилати
свої показники тиску онлайн і контролюватися фахівцями
на відстані. Попит росте у всьому світі.
Ще у 2015 році загальний обіг медичних послуг
онлайн становив близько 60 мільярдів євро.
Чотири роки по тому він подвоївся,
а за неповний 2020 рік вже сягнув 173 мільярдів євро.
Скепсис пацієнтів щодо медичних онлайнпропозицій зменшується.
Інвестори проявляють дедалі більшу готовність
підтримувати фінансово стартапи з новими технологіями.
Нам у Німеччині знайома проблема недофінансування
нових підприємств-стартапів, особливо на початковому етапі.
Тепер же у цьому сенсі відбулися зміни.
У сфері охорони здоров'я молоді фірми отримують нині
значно більше стартового капіталу і можуть проводити
серйозні розробки, як у США.
Стало можливим створювати команди фахівців і розвиватися.
Багато стартапів отримують зиск від популярності онлайнмедицини.
Шведське підприємство KRY розробило додаток
для пошуку лікарів для онлайнконсультацій.
Зареєструвавшись у ньому, пацієнт відповідає на запитання
про симптоми та отримує консультацію в бажаний час.
Наразі в їхній базі - близько 900 лікарів різного профілю:
Вірусні інфекції, бактеріальні інфекції, головний біль,
блювота, пронос, запалення очей.
Одним словом, усе, з чим зазвичай приходять
на терміновий прийом до терапевта.
Цим додатком уже скористалися, за даними фірми,
два мільйони разів. Він працює у скандинавських країнах,
Франції, Великобританії та Німеччині.
Відеочат з лікарем можливий німецькою або англійською мовами.
Рецепти, лікарняні бюлетені або квитанції видаються
в електронній формі. А як щодо захисту персональних даних?
Таке питання - це природно, коли з'являється щось нове,
особливо у сфері здоров'я.
Але мипомічаємо, що люди тестують це,
а тоді їм це починає подобатися. Вони бачать, що технологія
спрацьовує і що лікарі з хорошою кваліфікацією
та підготовкою у телемедичній сфері, багато на що здатні.
Онлайн-додатків у медицині з'явилося вже чимало.
Це стосується не лише діагностики лікарем онлайн, але й
догляду за хронічними хворими, замовлення медикаментів,
відстеження аналізів пацієнта, психотерапії тощо.
В Україні вже теж з'явилися подібні сервіси.
Деякі навіть рекламують себе як безкоштовні:
послуги оплачує Національна служба здоров'я.
Однак слід бути обережним, адже існують і платні сервіси.
Втім, як і зі звичайним візитом до лікаря.
Онлайнлікар доступний 24 години на добу сім днів на тиждень,
обіцяють компанії у сфері телемедицини.
Дуже перспективними називають такі консультації для мешканців сіл,
яким треба долати десятки кілометрів до найближчого лікаря.
Як би там не було, а телемедицина не замінить
фізичного візиту до лікаря у разі важких або небезпечних хвороб.
До речі, у Німеччині страхові каси тепер покривають
і кошти на лікування онлайн.